i think people are gonna be very hungry
for a season two when this
these eight episodes are benched through
in one day which is what i predict will
happen because it happened to me
um what would each of you like to see
happen in a season two i would
definitely love to see what happens with
the baby and how she's going to manage
miami versus tampa and really how the
ladies are going to either
put up a fight
or or not in terms of who else is going
to be second in command
[Laughter]
colony more of i think more of me you
know you see the
work colony you see colony you know
showing homes to our clients and hanging
out with anne and you know that's just
one aspect of my life i really want to
open up and get the world to see really
who colony is deep down so i'm hoping
for season two
you get more of a layer that's peeled
back for colony and maybe your
co-workers can stop thinking you're
dating everybody you're showing houses
to
listen first of all
if they were closing deals they won't
have time to worry about who i'm dating
okay here it is let's talk about that
the people who worry about me are not
closing deals
so but for season two maybe i have a
little boo a real boo
so
i'm putting that out in the atmosphere
yeah i was gonna say we will quote anne
sophie not a little boo we want a sixth
[Laughter]
it was brought to my attention that you
felt like i gave up on you i do how
i do i feel like you gave up before i
could actually like prove myself as a
realtor but you've been here for two
years alexa what would you look forward
to showcasing in season two in season
two i mean i i hope and pray that you
know alexis get her stuff together
because she was one of my you know first
agents and
if she does uh
maybe i can think about bringing her
back and
expanding the miami office and showing
these ladies that you know
i'm a badass [ __ ] so i know how
to handle both offices
sherrod rosado
point blank period alexis what would you
like to see happen in uh season two
other than maybe coming back to the
brokerage
i have high hopes for season two i
obviously hope that i can get to the
level that i deserve to be at you know
working hard getting more clients
uh showing more properties closing more
deals those are my goals hopefully that
means also coming back to lore with
welcoming arms with no drama
those are my goals for that and
obviously meeting baby serenity and so
forth and maybe getting the mls app
downloaded on your phone
somewhere
you know what the property taxes are
i believe
they were
six thousand i'm not 100 for sure i'll
check into that because i totally made
up six thousand denial what about you i
mean did we ever sell ben a house
no i didn't sell better house
but we're still working together on many
investment properties and i just like to
see show that you know i am still the
newest
um the crew and that i'm you know
getting a lot of
showings and i mean properties and
working hard i mean the houses on this
show are next level selling sunset is
one thing but i had no idea what real
estate gems were hiding over in florida
some beautiful houses something really
some beautiful things here it's already
hard for us to get into that luxury
market i want to show you guys it can be
done i have a whole family that i'm
juggling on top of you know running this
real estate business and
um it's really interesting i think
that's neat when you get to see women
who are ambitious and doing their thing
but they're also holding down you know
friends and family and doing their thing
and i think i think it's interesting so
i'd like to see more of that i would
love to
explore
more of like my actual like background
um my relationship with like uh
some of the quirks about me that are due
to my background um and you know
a tall boo maybe potentially
i would love to explore that
taking applications we're betting them
though
dms are open and i'm sure they will be
flooded on december 16th
carla what would you like to do in
season two so i'll sum up a little bit
about what reena said um so we do have
families i do i am a single mother i
have three boys
and i have another business that i
tend to so i kind of want to show that
part of it where i'm really pushing
myself to get back into real estate and
show that entrepreneur side of me as
well
[Music]
you